all right good evening everyone and
welcome to our panel on writing drama in
this discussion our panelists or writers
with experience who explored former in
their work will discuss the complexities
of writing drama how to write drama
ethically how to write trauma without
cannibalizing one's experiences how to
balance the craft of writing with the
craft of writing trauma and ultimately
what it means to write trauma I'm here
on behalf of the Yale women faculty
forum and we're very happy to be joined
in support of this event by the program
in women gender and sexuality studies by
the English department the Native
American Cultural Center the office of
LGBTQ resources and the afro-american
cultural center I should mention this
event is being recorded by Yale
broadcasting I should also mention that
we will have a bit of a change of plan
with live questions from the audience
rather than written questions and so we
will have microphones that will go up
and down the the aisles at the question
period at the end so without further ado
let me introduce our moderator and our
panelists for this evening our moderator
for this evening is dr. Melanie Boyd
Melanie Boyd is director of the Office
of gender and campus culture a lecture
in the women gender and sexuality
studies program an assistant dean in
Yale College dean's office she has a PhD
in English and Women's Studies and she
wrote a dissertation on the rhetorical
politics of innocence agency and
sentimentality in feminist trauma
narratives
Melanie's current work focuses on sexual
violence and in cultural transformation
drawing on feminist and queer theory
along with research in public health and
psychology she has created a nationally
recognized program for preventing sexual
violence through positive cultural
change and now our panelists dr. Tracy
McMillan Karim is a digital sociologist
professor writer and columnist she's
spoken across the nation and across the
world on technology higher education
race gender class and social inequality
audiences and readers connect with her
ability to make complex ideas relatable
her latest book which is called thick
draws on ten years of writing for the
public on many of our societies
pressing fault lines it joins her other
books including the acclaimed lower
aired as a genre busting academic career
that spans public policy to cultural
critique Therese Murray Mayer it's from
the sea bird island band in British
Columbia her work has appeared in Granta
the LA Times Guernica Pacific Standard L
Mother Jones as well as elsewhere she's
the author of Hart berries and memoir
it's a story of love and violence and
Hart buries one the public the New York
Public Library's best book of the Year
award and was an MP our best book of the
year as well she teaches creating a
creative writing at Purdue University
where she's a visiting assistant
professor or Bri Hirsch is the author of
why we never talk about sugar a short
story collection and this will be his
legacy a flash vixen chat book her
stories essays and comics have appeared
in many outlets for example the American
short fiction the Florida review black
warrior review the nib the rumpus and
the New York Times
Sayyed Jones is a next panelist
his debut poetry collection prelude to
Bruges was the winner of the 2015 pen
Joyce Oscar Wilde award for poetry and
the 2015 stone will Brook award and the
Brava Keating's a literature award it
was also a finalist for the 2015
National Book Critics Circle Award the
collection was a finalist for 200 2015
awards from the lambda literary and
publishing triangle and his memoir how
we fight for our lives will be published
by Simon & Schuster this fall and Roxane
gay who writes on feminism race gender
and intersections is a presidential
visiting fellow at Yale this semester
she's a contributing opinion writer to
the New York Times the author of the
books 80 an untamed state and the New
York Times bestseller bad feminist also
the nationally best-selling difficult
women and the New York Times bestseller
hunger so without further ado please
join me in welcoming our guests and have
a good evening
Thanks Thank You Claire and the forum WS
w GSS and everyone else for organizing
this and being here tonight and thanks
to all of you for being here um I want
to just jump into this conversation I am
so interested to hear all of your
different pieces the Claire has um just
quoted for us Roxanne's framing
questions the house right how does one
write ethically without cannibalizing
oneself louder am i not miked them out
loud enough
yeah the mic fire I have to raise my mic
higher thank you everyone
how's that better thank you okay so
before we get to the house which i think
is going to be the heart of our
conversation I wanted to start a little
bit with the Hoos and the what's when
you're writing anything thinking about
who your audience is how you're
connecting with them what it is you want
them to take away from your writing is
of course at the heart of it when you're
writing about trauma that becomes even
more complicated and I know none of your
audiences are singular I'm particularly
interested in hearing about how those
different intersecting audiences that
you have who are you thinking of from
when you write what do you want them to
hear what do you want them to take away
so I want to just kind of open that up
yeah oh my god Wow okay that's a good
question the reality is I don't think of
anyone but myself when I write I write
for myself
mm-hm and I have no regrets about that
because when I think too much about
audience I tend to compromise the
integrity of it what it is that I want
to say I think about pandering too much
because I want to say something that
will please people so I pretend that no
one's gonna read my work partly so I
have the courage to put it out into the
world and partly so I don't compromise
what I want to say and in that I tried
to write the things that would have
helped me when I most needed that kind
of help
regardless of whatever topic it is that
I'm writing about
trusty what about you one because I
believe a come from a black feminist
tradition where you have to name your
position ality and so that's mine
but like Roxanne once I sit down to
actually write I have to think of no one
and one of the things I've said to
people about that is like Roxanne if I'm
thinking about the audience my you know
I do a version of nonfiction writing
where I am trying to make an argument I
am trying to put forward a way of
thinking about the world and so that
comes with I think a certain type of
responsibility and because it is an
argument if I am thinking too much about
the audience I start to write for both
of us
I start to write my argument and the
counter-argument which is an excellent
way to lose your voice in the writing
and to lose your place and lose your
thread of your thinking in your argument
so I actually have to forget and assume
that no one is ever going to read it I
have to and have learned over time to
trust that my final product will circle
back to my politics and my beliefs and
my ethics which is the process I'm I
would actually say only recently have I
been able to say with uh with complete
certainty that I trust myself when I
forget the audience that I'm still gonna
write what I intended to write and so
I'm not writing for them at that time
and that became especially important I
think when writing about trauma because
I wanted to defend myself and I wanted
to defend the people whose stories are
implicated in my story that's the thing
about writing part of your own biography
right all of our biographies are
interwoven with other people's
biographies and I think in thinking
about the audience too much I would have
compromised too much of my narrative not
even probably for myself but for others
and so I don't think about anyone I
tried to keep my laser focus on what is
the thing I sat down to do
am i putting forward an argument that I
think is something that only I can write
I only ever want to write the thing that
only I can write if someone else can
write it I wait for them to write it and
read it Frank actually makes my life
much easier but with the trauma
especially for me to stay focused in the
space that I need to be in to write
about it I have to not write for anyone
I mean you know black feminist politics
and and art saved my life taught me how
to save my life so I think it's no
coincidence that certainly how I think
about this certainly in light of what
you've both said I would especially with
writing about trauma and nonfiction I am
thinking about myself but I'm thinking
of it as like time travel usually and
it's vague but it's like when conceiving
the project I'm trying to imagine if in
2019 knowing everything I know about
where I ended up who I now know right
the the the queer friends and and the
women and the mentors and mentees that
are now a part of my life and it brought
all of the colour to my life now if I
could step into a portal and come out on
the other side at the precise moment
that a past version of myself most
needed that color what would I say
what would I reach through the portal
you know what would be the book or the
essay or the poem or the little bit of
advice you know that I would hope you
know Sayid and you know January of 2008
the morning after a you know a lover has
tried to beat him up and kill him you
know when he's getting on the plane back
to college and trying to figure out how
he feels
what does he need to hear that morning
or Sayid
you know summer room I don't know 2003
and he's at the public library in
Lewisville Texas looking for books about
being gay and they're all either about
AIDS or they're about dealing with your
gay child as if it's a cancer diagnosis
what would be best in that moment
you know and so it is thinking about
myself but like with that intentionality
that is rooted in the power of knowing
and I think everyone on the stage can
speech at this of feeling the peril of
feeling alone even if it's not accurate
right but feeling alone in moments of
trauma or post trauma how can we reach
ourselves this is also interesting to
hear I my thoughts on that are a little
bit different because I actually don't
know that I'm ready to write about
something that I experienced as trauma
until I can think about it in an outward
way you know if I'm if I'm thinking
about you know my past self or someone
in my same position or just myself then
it's for me that means it's too raw or I
don't yet know what I want to say about
it and it's not until I start to think
about how I can turn this into something
that can teach someone something or
connect with someone you know on a more
universal level that I feel like I'm I'm
actually ready to approach it and maybe
it's just because it's too it's too
scary or or it somehow makes it feel
like it had value like that it's that
horrible experience that it had value
because now I can turn it into something
that does have value but yeah for me I I
am kind of more audience forward I guess
when I'm writing this kind of material I
do you know I think of my self I don't I
don't think anyone will read it which I
think liberate Smee because I live
before audiences most of my life like
you know like welfare workers they want
you to be pitiful so that you can get
the resources so you don't get to
present your real selves and men on a
date you're trying to assume that you
have good credit you don't you
to assume that you're not battered or
that you're not broken inside so that
they will love you
you know I've I don't think those people
when I write but I know they're watching
now and I think it's gonna do something
for the social worker who did my
casework to read the book and know that
I had an interior life and I think
that's really important for native women
I mean it seems to me that that's part
of the challenges is staying true to the
thing that you want to say to the person
who you want to reach in the past or the
present with with that awareness always
that there are all these other audiences
sort of circling around in different
ways when we come to the question that I
know you've been working on in your
classes well Roxana what does it mean to
write trauma ethically I'm curious I
mean I think that's part of it but what
are what does that challenge mean to you
as you're sitting down to write what are
the pieces that you're trying to
navigate yeah that's a question that I
have been really preoccupied with for
about 10 years because that's when I
first started writing about my trauma
publicly and at the time I was working
on my first novel an untamed state and
it involves the kidnapping and some
brutality sexual violence and then the
recovering and the aftermath and as I
thought about that I just wanted to make
sure that I was telling the story well
of course and that I was telling the
story ethically that I wasn't writing
these scenes of violence in a way that
was gratuitous and were overly stylized
because all too often when we see people
write about trauma they make it seem
like this gauzy sort of almost beautiful
experience from which there is immediate
and profound Redemption and that's not
necessarily the reality of reality and
so for me the most important
consideration was how do I do this
honestly how do I do this in a way that
people don't think oh what a beautiful
scene because if I'm writing about a
rape it's not beautiful it's ugly and I
want the reader to feel like it's ugly I
want them to feel the importance of it
and I also want them to actually not be
able to read it
I think that you should be able to write
violence in ways that are honest and
unreadable because when it's readable
that means that it's something that
you're compelled to read so I just try
to be true as possible to the actual
realities and I also want to make sure
that I'm not reach Ramat izing readers
who have had similar experiences or who
find this kind of experience which I
hope is everyone deeply unacceptable and
so it's a fine line between being
explicit and being open and being true
and also making sure that you are not
traumatizing the reader Roxanne and
everyone and I'm thinking about ethics
for me operating on a feud a couple
different levels so I read a lot about
the the institutional violence that is
enacted particularly on black women and
and through my own experience of it I
talk about my experience in the
healthcare system for example in the
medical field and I had to make a couple
of choices so one was a choice about
voice I was thinking about when Roxanne
just said which was I if you could leave
that essay unscathed I would have
thought I had done it unethically and I
think that there is that some readers
are motivated to slip into the interior
lives of people who are different from
them particularly minoritized people and
to enjoy the in violence this sort of
visceral effect of enjoy enjoying the
violence and getting all of a sort of
sexual cognitive thrill of watching the
violence and acted upon us and then they
get to leave unscathed
right and so my first ethical choice was
I did not want to write that and in fact
I remember saying to my editor if I
write this I'm gonna give it a shot
right cuz I didn't want to write it
frankly and I thought I'm gonna give it
a shot but if I think that anybody can
read this and leave this story without
feeling implicated it would have been
too
an unethical retelling of the trauma so
that's one of my things that I tried to
keep in mind I debated with myself quite
a bit the extent to which I would reveal
identifying characteristics of others
and then I just came down on the side of
you know if you did it to me then you
deserve the story you deserve the
retelling but my defense there is always
that it be honest if it was as honest as
I could be and I mean I I tried to be as
honest in the telling of the big pieces
of the story as I am in the details
right so sometimes I think we can write
trauma because we are so committed so
just having people feel this thing that
the details can get mired down it's
something that can be a little untrue
and the less true the details are to me
the less ethical the telling is because
my goal is for you to see how brutal and
traumatic everyday routine violence is I
don't want to make it more exceptional
than what it is I don't want it to be
fantastical right I don't want sparkles
and slow-moving bodies I want you to
look at a bureaucratic form and feel as
though somebody has reached inside of
you and taking something out of you
because that's what they all can do to
people right and so for me it is to
ground the trauma and as many honest
details as I can to try to keep an
ethical check on myself and then there's
a constant conversation with myself how
I can I can only do that well when it's
scabbed over right I read Kia's a
Lyman's book heavy recently which I
highly recommend to everyone and at the
end I remember throwing the book across
the room which means I enjoyed it
I mean who really didn't you understand
what it was yeah who's with me saying I
don't look good emotion I'm with you but
because it took me a while ago Oh cuz he
had written before his scab was done and
I just felt completely convicted in the
reading of the head and so I am now in a
conversation with her stuff and I say
they say I don't have a good answer to
this part of the ethical layer because
I'm still debating it he brought
something up for me about whether or not
we can do that while we're still
processing the trauma I don't know my
general my rule before reading heavy
have been I only write about the trauma
once I had the scab right because the
thing with the trauma is that people are
going to poke at it right once there's
an audience they're gonna poke at it and
so but I don't know I took something
from him and I'm now debating that with
myself I didn't I think they look for
good victims and survivors stories where
you transcend the experience who you
become a better person for the sake of
that trauma or something like that I
didn't I didn't want to be just when I
had postpartum depression I want to
write the worst thing I did as a mother
and so that so that I could write well
about it because I hadn't seen a book
that even took the shame off of that
mental exhaustion and everything I went
through but I wasn't just I didn't
rationalize my actions and that was
really important because it made the
potency of what was done to me even more
potent because when you have a full
character that is traumatized by
something so regular it's always typical
how they heard us all right why should
we write it in a literary styling if
it's just up and down this way so that
was really important I think it up the
potency because you saw me as a human
being really fallible and also trouble
but also smart you know and full and
then yeah you see how that was stripped
from me
you know and I think that was that was
ethical I also I don't want to tour
anyone in my grief or in my trauma
because I think people are titillated
when they can see our experiences as a
poor Indian or as an Indian with a
drunken father but I didn't want to or
anybody through that I wanted to put
them in my journey which you know is
hard to exact and execute yeah I think
as a man on this stage you know and
writing about trauma there are some
moments of difference even as a gay man
right like particularly when writing
about violence like there is actually
such an extensive body of work about men
grappling with violence you know I
wouldn't I would read how straight white
men and the 20th century would write
about boxing for example I would you
know certainly would read about violence
enacted on gay men and black men and so
became aware of a few things that you
know one noticing the patterns noticed
noticing like the banality of male
violence in terms of how it's typically
written about reported on and discussed
and and because I'm telling my story and
I'm there like okay Matthew Shepard
Jamesburg jr. Tamir rice they can't come
back unfortunately and say you all we're
looking here but if you look here right
in this moment you will notice something
and so I realized I could do that I had
the opportunity to shift the weight and
you know I wanted to be difficult too
and so I tried to look at even in
moments of someone is possibly going to
kill me right if this man succeeds in
this moment if I let go of his hands he
could absolutely bash my head into this
floor and I could die but also I still
have an erection right now I'm still
turned on
because this is a lover and I was like
let's bring that into it
also I'm angry at him I think he's dumb
like I was trying to to look at I think
him I'm better than him because I am in
a Women's Studies class right now and I
understand you know like literally like
I remember like literally on the floor
wrestling for my life and I'm thinking
about bell hooks and I'm thinking about
Audrey Lord and I'm thinking about how
arrogant I feel even as this knowledge
clearly has not prevented me from ending
up in this situation so I found in like
kind of doing like a counterweight to
the weight of the Canon in terms of how
we write about these moments with men I
felt important both for like the bigger
picture but also for myself to
demonstrate like I am a victim but
victims are still people and I don't
deserve what happened to me but my full
humanity was in that room when it
happened and part of that means is that
I was just as complicated as the man who
was trying to kill me
and that unfortunately when we hear
about people particularly who don't
survive those moments right that is
what's taken away you know you you see
the way Emmett Till's mother you know
has to talk about Emmett Till and it's
very strategic because she has to
galvanize literally an international
movement to even get the coffin to
Chicago by the way right they weren't
even gonna get the boys coffin there so
she had to actually cast him as a nun
totally naive totally innocent figure he
had no idea about the virulence of
racism in Mississippi because he was
from Chicago how should he know though
my father was of course very segregated
like she had to do that and I'm sure if
he came back and had you know
opportunity K might say but mom you know
so that's what we have the opportunity
to say what are the ethics of saying but
mom in that moment right right figuring
out how how the trauma story does not
become simplified right because there's
so much pressure on the weight of it to
simplify it so
absolutely and we have this very
singular idea of victimhood and Sayid
points out that if you've suffered you
are a saint and we see this all the time
in the public sphere where when
something bad happens to you all of a
sudden you become canonized
but the alternative especially when
you're a person of color is that you
need to be canonized in order to get
some consideration and Tamir rice is an
incredible example because he was just a
boy playing in a park and people were
like well he shouldn't have been playing
with a toy gun in a park where were his
parents so we have to say no he's an
innocent perfect twelve-year-old boy
because otherwise his life doesn't
matter and we have to do the same thing
when we're writing about our stories and
when we're writing about how we suffered
the reality is I don't want to be
canonized like I am a deeply deeply
flawed individual and that frankly makes
me more interesting but that doesn't
diminish the ways in which I have
suffered it doesn't absolve those who
have caused me harm and I think the more
we write about these nuances and are
real about our imperfections and the
ways we've suffered the better we are
going to tell stories about trauma yeah
and certainly none of your stories any
of you on this stage are oversimplified
or innocent or write this this is what
makes you all so wonderful here that
your capacity to tell this more complex
story I'm wondering about I'm sort of
going back to my question about who
you're writing for right because to the
extent that the sort of first pass of
that was about writing for your earlier
selves this feels to me like part of
that is is being able to hold out for
those selves or the the sort of
permutations of those selves that are
out in the world the notion that in
order to have this count you don't have
to have been fully innocent and as I say
that I don't mean this that the
complexity always has to be there right
because the flipside is as soon as you
give up on the innocence then well it
wants to been all your fault or you know
you must have deserved it so keeping
that
just seems so critical tied into that
balance I think is the you were speaking
about this a few minutes ago the need to
move between the individual the
specificity of the individual stories
and all of the broader cultural patterns
right the patterns of power and
privilege and oppression that the
histories the very particular histories
that you're tapping into that gives
those individual specificities their
meaning and at the same time those those
are very patterns are so often about the
erasure of specificity right so once you
try to get those things in dialogue with
each other I'm curious about that if you
could talk about how you are from all of
your really different angles weighing
these broader the broader circulating
dynamics without ever having that lose
sight of the person the actual whole
human person at the center yeah it's an
interesting question you know how you
kind of add in research to your piece to
give it that kind of universal feeling
or to tap into what's going on you know
some of my writing a lot of my writing
has to do with medicine and trauma or
science and trauma in some way like
memory and trauma or just trying to be a
woman and get help in the medical
institution which is quite challenging
that has led to traumatic experiences
for me and yeah I definitely try to do
both of those things I think it's almost
like a spoonful of sugar makes the
medicine go down kind of thing where you
can be attempting to educate people
about a problem but a lot of people are
not going to read that article unless
there's a narrative because you know
people like a story and they like a
feeling and just reading a set of
statistics about women being
misdiagnosed or under diagnosed or
turned away is not going to be
compelling but if you can give people an
emotional arc that goes like this
they'll read it and
they'll take it in they'll take in the
other stuff with it so I think even if
it might be interesting for me to just
write you a list of statistics about
women and medicine and it would be very
interesting and I could give you a lot
of them it might not be interesting to
listen to
until I can say well listen to what
happened to me you know like let me tell
you about the list of medications that I
took let me tell you about you know I
had a heart attack and I didn't get an
EKG for 6 hours because I'm I was a
young woman and I got to pregnancy tests
before I got an EKG both were negative
but you know and that makes you do that
right and makes you go in the way that
if I say you know 75% of women with
autoimmune disorders are misdiagnosed
for more than five years you're like huh
interesting that's an interesting fact
but it doesn't necessarily compel you
emotionally so yeah I kind of see the
two as in some ways inextricable like if
I just tell you my story it's just my
story if I just tell you the statistics
it's just this statistics but if you can
put them together then hopefully you can
make something that you know ideally
might make a difference yeah and of
course the statistics are also woven
into the conditions that create your
story in the first place right but it's
not there all of a piece
yeah I'm implicated in this in
particular because I'm called to do it
because I'm a sociologist right and so
that's what I'm trained to do you know
in Western culture we we love to
separate you know
the rational way of knowing the world
from the emotional way of knowing the
world and one of the things that I tried
to do in my writing is to reconnect
those two things so you know to the
point of you know I can tell you a
statistic but can I make you feel a
statistic yeah right it's just for me
the creative challenge quite frankly it
is can I write structure narrative Li
that is also honest to the empirics so
for me this is a false divide between
what we know and how we come to know it
our senses are how we come to know right
our intellect maybe the process by which
we come to believe we know but those two
are actually always operating at the
same time in to the extent that we have
ever separated those two I think it is a
false divide and I think the power of
something like trauma because trauma is
one of the few spaces because it's such
an extreme it's such an emotional
extreme I think it's one of the few
places where we aren't able to deny that
both of those things are happening the
trauma is usually being enacted upon you
because of some macro process right that
is occurred right it's the moment when
you feel history of biography and
politics and trauma is also the moment
that interrupts all of the ways we've
lied to ourselves about our emotions
okay and so it is in trauma where I
think we have a particular opportunity
to get rid of the false dichotomy of
those two ways of knowing the world and
that's why it's challenging but I also
think it's why it's probably more
possible there than it is in some other
narrative retellings and so for me yeah
the challenge is always to ground again
I feel called to do so the creative
challenge for me is trying to do so well
but also I think it is the most powerful
form of knowledge it is the one that I
think is most where I am living my
responsibility to any sort of inherited
knowledge --is that I have at the same
time that I honor any sort of acquired
knowledge as I have accumulated during
my own life it's the moment when I get
to live up to both of those and the
challenge for me is
do it and so I try to do that in every
piece but I feel especially responsible
for doing it when I'm writing about
drama I feel like one of the deeper and
more dangerous flaws or features of men
and in terms of how we write about our
experiences is the tendency to lean on
the side of I am the only one let's
think has happened to or and it is the
most significant version of whatever you
know for the smile you know like that
there's this wane in it you know it's
connected to all kinds of reasons but
you know because you know straight rich
white cisgender men are set up to write
whatever is gonna be the great American
better day you know so that's a part so
knowing that knowing you know I did not
read books by men by choice until I was
almost in graduate school because I was
so resistant and disgusted by what I saw
in classrooms you know and so feeling
that so viscerally I tried to compensate
for it in my own writing and so I I
found that with my own experience the
two great fortunes for me was one time
I'm a slower writer than I realized
like I book I started writing the essay
that became this book actually the week
after I got back to campus in 2008 write
writing then an essay about it actually
was how I began to deal with it so long
time and I you know I sold the book 20
spring to 2015 I thought I'd be done in
like a year or two and I'm almost up
right so it just took time but but by
the grace of time you know you're able
to step further and further away from
like I am the only one is the most
dedicated death so that helped the other
thing is you know I've been in a
newsroom I've been working at BuzzFeed
for six years now first as LGBT editor
culture editor and now I host a morning
show and so I've been surrounded by
reporters
and I've gotten to see with such great
respect how they do their job and you
naturally begin to soak it up and so as
time kind of you know kept stretching
out and I'm working on this book I would
start talking about what I was working
on and you know it just happens I can't
keep a secret about something I care
about that I'm working when it come you
know we're at a bar like where I'm gonna
start talking about it and I started
paying attention to other people sharing
their stories I'll never forget like
telling I'm a young we were like edimar
it as loud as how it was like two
o'clock in the morning and a guy like
here's what I'm writing about and he's
like oh yeah I met a guy at a party once
and I went back to his place and we had
sex and I woke up in the middle of the
night and he was gone and all of his
roommates were just standing around the
bed looking at me and I mean it's like
mute like rock music you know and I was
just stunned and so I've had so many of
those moments that I can't pretend I'm
the only person or the most special or
the most hurtful or the most wise and
and so then when I go back to write I
tried as best I can to not to really bow
frankly to all of those other people
because when I read those work by you
know those classic male you know
novelist and writers that's what I don't
see I don't see the bow the humility to
other people you know I know my text is
informed by statistics like personally
statistics offend like they're
weaponized against indigenous people
continually they do no service to me I
already know we have a bad but I know my
text is informed I if I committed I
committed to the book and the book said
it helped the women in my family up here
and I had to start learning that they
were gonna be my primary source for
history it wasn't going to be silly
translations of indigenous knowledge it
was going to be the women in my family
and if I was going to make a text that
was legacy it had to hold the history
and be honest and accountable
and drew so I think it changed history
for me yeah you know yeah
and that's the text is informed by all
the all the information it's informed
you know by Roxanne's work it's informed
by all the poets I read and you can see
that in the quality of the work so in a
lot of ways I didn't need to expand and
give data and qualify all of my things
with lived experience of others because
of all in the text you can feel it you
know it's night and day reading a writer
who reads passionately and with humility
and a writer who does not it might still
be good work but I think like it once I
started realizing that that was such a
value for me and reading interviews from
other writers who can't make it through
the other engine make it throughout an
interview without praising someone else
once you begin to notice that I think it
says a lot because it's actually a
worldview it's not a small detail I
think about this quite a lot because I'm
actually a rhetorician by trade and so
especially during my doctoral education
I was thinking quite a lot about the
rhetorical appeals and ethos pathos
logos and how you craft an argument to
be believed and so I do rely on external
factors like statistics and anok data to
bolster my personal experience as Aubrey
says where people aren't going to care
if you don't give them that emotional
appeal if you don't give them that
reason to care but one of the things
especially as I get older and more
mature as a writer is that I try to
resist universality because people try
to flatten experiences and they say well
I can't relate to that
so it must have no value and one of the
things especially as a black woman that
I want to do is assert that my narrative
and people who look like me and live in
bodies like mine our stories matter
whether or not Becky can relate and it
goes a long way to I think making my
work have an impact when I move that way
and one of the most surprising things is
because I have done it well is that
people who I would think have wildly
different
from mine can relate sometimes
specificity matters and I try to
prioritize that so I'm curious Roxanne
you have this fabulous phrase about the
how does one write trauma without
cannibalizing oneself one's own
experiences the experiences of others
can you unpack what what are you
thinking of with that and I'm curious to
hear you a little play around a little
bit with this idea yes you know
oftentimes when you're a marginalized
person people think that the only thing
you can be an expert on is yourself and
what you've experienced so if you're a
woman you have to write about being a
woman if you're LGBTQ you can only write
about that experience if you're black or
a person of color that's all you can
write about if you've been traumatized
that's all you can write about you can't
write about say climate change and you
know oftentimes we contain multitudes
and we do want to write about things
that go beyond our subject position but
when we do write from our subject
position
we shouldn't have to cannibalize
ourselves and by that I mean we
shouldn't have to tell you every gory
detail I remember when bad feminists
came out there's an essay in it called
what we hunger for and in it I write
about my sexual assault but I don't
offer any real details about it and a
woman reviewed it and she said that when
she realized I wasn't going to detail my
assault she threw the book across the
room but not because she loved it
and she was just so angry and
disappointed that I didn't give all the
gory details she felt robbed and cheated
yeah and I have never forgotten that
first of all I'm Petty and I don't
forget anything
I remember every word of every bad
review you're welcome
but what really stunned me was that she
needed me to tell her the most intimate
details things that my partner doesn't
even know and why why did you want me to
eat my own flesh in that way for your
delectation it's not necessary and so I
strongly encourage any writer who's
writing from the personal to really
consider what you're saying and why who
do you think you're appeasing does it
serve the narrative that you're trying
to put into the world does it contribute
to the purpose that you're trying to
fulfill and if it doesn't save it
keep your boundaries firm know what your
boundaries are before you go into it
because the publishing industry is
definitely going to try and get you to
compromise your boundaries at every
opportunity and so if you're not willing
to stick to them they will take
everything from you and you'll have
nothing left for yourself you'll have no
privacy and I just didn't want to put
certain images in the heads of the
people who love me most you don't need
to know like this terrible thing to know
I went through a terrible thing and so I
just really resist it and when I see
people cannibalizing themselves for $50
mind you which is the going rate I just
feel so sad because it costs them far
more than they received we were talking
about this last night in Roxanne's class
about how there is a huge market for
this sort of like trauma Zoo right where
you can take this a terrible thing that
happened to you and put it out for $50
on the internet and say look at this
horrible thing can you believe it that
happened to me that horrible thing you
see that let's all look at this horrible
thing that happened to me
and it's it bums me out you know like
when I see those essays getting churned
out by people or chinle by women and
young yeah definitely yeah we're not
while there is a market for it for
you know able-bodied white Western men
is not nearly a sizeable a market for
that as it is from women people have
called all the people that our culture
loves to hate women people color young
people and queer people right there is a
huge market for wanting to consume them
and I think about Roxanne Colin
cannibalization because you know you
know coming from bell hooks is thinking
about the eating of the other this idea
that we are at a point in consumerism
well now we want you to show it show
yourself eating yourself right it's a
very black mirror ask sort of satire I
want to state I think of this stage of
capitalism and the way we consume things
the way we consume people is how we also
consume information we don't want to
consume it anymore we want to watch you
get consumed and consume yourself and we
have a particular set I think of
perverse economic incentives to get
people to do that I said I actually I
called Roxanne before I put out that
because I had written some of the most
personal things I had ever published
before and what she said to me was oh
you only do what you want to do and I
remember thinking oh well that hadn't
occurred to me but as it turned out you
really can do that you can only do what
you want to do and similarly you are
saying you know I have people I must say
disproportionately white women by the
way who are extremely angry with me is
for the same reason they want to know
details about right how long was my
daughter alive how long did it take
before I got the epidural which at what
kind of epidural did I get what kind of
medication you say you were on something
but you didn't say what right and I get
these long dramatic emails from them
about this and then one don't respond to
their emails they write me letters on a
piece of paper which I just think it's
an exceptional level of commitment
[Laughter]
think about what you had to go through
to get a spam well you don't just start
lying around anymore we're in a
difference anyway and they send these
things to me and what I think I have
come to learn about that though is about
you call it the trauma Zoo and there's a
history of the human Zoo in our culture
right and what I think they cannot abide
by is the sense of agency in the
narrative of the trauma we are more
comfortable accepting agency from some
writers as opposed to others and I think
it is a function of Who I am writing
about something how dare you make me
think about something when I don't know
everything about you how dare you make a
decision about what you'll tell me so
few people have ever had to deal with
someone who looks like me exercising
their agency without them being able to
use their power to push back and the
thing is in a text the author has
already given you what they're going to
give you all a reader can do is try to
hound you to give them more and so they
want to extract it from you and feel
that in the real world outside of the
text they can make me do it
and I'm like Roxanna I both push back on
it and now tell my students and people
talk to me you know very similar things
about there is something about once you
once you release it you never get it
back one and once you release it it can
be turned into something that you no
longer have any control over and so the
entire narrative that you have poured
your intellectual and creative energies
into painstakingly creating write can be
remixed and transposed against your will
and the more you give people of that to
do right the more they'll do it and so
yeah do you think there is a fine line
between what I'm willing to give to
people versus what they want me to give
to them and the other component of it is
not not only do they want to know
everything and feel like they're owed
everything part of it is that they don't
believe you and so what they're saying
is prove it right and you see this all
in ways that are very minor and small
like idiots on Twitter who are like
debate me
like prove me wrong like [ __ ]
you were born wrong and when you relate
trauma and you don't give dates and
times and names all of a sudden what you
have to say is illegitimate because they
don't want to believe that this kind of
suffering can happen and it's a truly
dangerous thing I don't have to prove to
you that what I said happened happened I
only had to prove it to my publisher and
the legal team there right but I don't
owe you [ __ ]
and it's really important for writers to
know that your truth is your truth and
do people lie absolutely but why
publishing doesn't pay that well yeah it
just doesn't I got $15,000 for bad
feminist that's not enough money to bare
my soul also I mean did y'all know y'all
will go on to the mountaintop tonight
but we're there I have to bring in just
oh my goodness the depth of what is
being said from my perspective as an
editor as an executive editor working
you know selecting soliciting publishing
editing personal essays and all of this
on the someone's writing a book and all
of this one in the best case scenario
let's say you published that piece the
best case scenario is whatever you give
people are going to want more right you
publish the book then they wanted to be
a movie isn't that the dream oh baby
it's an audio play now oh maybe it's
apply like the best-case scenario
whatever it is it's going to be more
more questions more Twitter followers
more people in your mentions more
letters more emails are you ready for
that are you sure the other thing is and
as you said like you know however much
are being paid it will never it will
never be enough and that's why we don't
do this for the money because there's no
money in the world that can give you
back the worst night of your life but
even with that the $50 the $200 the
honorarium the market is depreciating
you know and I'm saying this as someone
who's been again at BuzzFeed news for
six years you're not dumb you know
what's happening in
the industry okay here's what you need
to know that sa you think that you're
going to write and you're going to
cannibalize the worst night of your life
and it's going to go viral and a million
people are going to read it or two
million people are going to read it and
you're going to get a book deal I am
here to tell you friends because of the
way the industry is going because of
Facebook and Google gobbling up ad
dollars viral content is no longer
profitable okay so that means these
media outlets no longer even have an
incentive actually to value as much as
they did a few years ago they're not
pretending and so they can now they're
forced to cannibalize themselves and
their own content quite frankly and I
say that someone who's proud to do the
work I do but I say that because you
just just look at young writers who
cannot wait to publish this essay about
this is just transformative experience
and I understand that I once felt that
way and I'm so grateful that I was
protected by mentors who slowed me down
or mentors who are an editor and said no
I reject it it was the best thing that
could ever happen to me because you're
throwing yourself into a hurricane and I
think these transformative experiences
frankly are finite I hope they are I
hope we only have so many experiences in
our lives that we can go I can write a
good personal essay about that right you
know and so just when you're doing that
and you're walking into that hurricane
it's just so much it's got to kind of be
taken away from you and sometimes it's
worth it you know what what
Roxanne has offered to us with the body
of her work is truly an offering and I
think I'm not the only person in this
room who's just like deeply grateful and
I know it's changed my life but there is
a cost and she's aware of it right but
when you are a younger writer oh my
goodness
yeah it's just scary how much you know
younger writers don't
yeah I'm currently hiring an editor for
a project and one of the duties is on
the job listing is that you have to be
willing to protect writers and you have
to be unwilling to hang writers out to
dry for clicks because I'm not
interested in clicks now who knows how
long that financial models going to work
but it's important that in addition to
writer is not cannibalizing themselves
we have to develop a culture of editing
and producing that doesn't expect the
cannibalization it goes both ways like
supply and demand stop demanding this
supply so that people can tell the
stories they want to tell for whatever
reason but be protected and doing so
because a Sayyid very aptly points out
you are not ready for the Maelstrom
that's going to come and there will be
no windfall at the end of it it just is
not going to happen and you can point to
one or two stories but that's one or two
out of thousands thousands yeah and I
listen it's like Cassandra you know it's
like she's out here saying like climate
change is coming y'all you know whatever
was like whatever you know I understand
like that is actually why it's so hard
you know mentoring and being a mentee is
we tend to think yeah but you ain't got
nothing like I got you know what I mean
so all I can say is like with deep
prayer finds your people you know you
you have to have your people I I just
think of like experiences like when I
was a kid and I would just do something
so obnoxious at school or whatever and I
would come home and my mom would be so
disappointed in me and I think but but
you know so so and who would who and why
and why they loved it you know you have
to find your people who will do that
because it's absolutely true in so many
ways and this isn't just essay writing I
mean just take this you know just more
generally there are always people who
will let you make a damn fool of
yourself and they will smile and they
will laugh and they will do everything
when they're with you but know that when
you're
alone they're not going to be there for
you so you have to find someone who can
protect you from those folks and I think
to be able also to like this is probably
a deeply unhealthy thing to say but to
be able to disassociate yourself from
your experience is also like really
helpful when you're a writer like to be
able to back up a little bit and when
people are talking about you on the
Internet it's not really you you know or
to have a sense of humor about it like
when I the one time I did go viral was
about this not being believed by doctors
and you know as you could probably guess
my whole Twitter timeline was men who
didn't believe me
that I hadn't been bullied I was like
this is so puzzling why would this
happen and there was a whole sub reddit
thread that was done picking apart my
story and explaining why this couldn't
possibly be true and any first-year
medical student would have diagnosed
this instantaneously and yada yada yada
and it's I was able to have a sense of
humor about it and to say like you know
this is literally what I'm talking about
like you are proving my point right now
and that's really important because
otherwise that that stuff can be really
hurtful and re-traumatize and damaging
especially when the whole point you're
trying to make and I think a lot of
trauma stems from this is like I didn't
have agency in the thing that happened
to me and then people just immediately
try to take it away again when you try
to own it right right and that can be
challenging if you can't get distance
and look at it with an outsider's eye I
know I haven't written something well if
the only takeaway is that Tommy about X
experience I know a book is not well
received or whatever if it's like this
taught me so much about the native
experience so I aim to go beyond
yeah I mean you're all talking in such
compelling ways about the support that
you need in the kind of perspective as a
writer I'm curious about the that maybe
the the sort of where would you divide
if you are looking at a piece of writing
and thinking is this a self
cannibalizing piece or is this doing
something else I have some ideas but I
want to hear your ideas about what are
the things you see in those pieces and I
think you're starting to point us there
right it takes us somewhere other than
oh now I know about that experience
there's nothing because they go where
they come in and they go in there they
don't care you know yeah and so all of
those books do very well because people
want to say they don't want what to say
if you want to make a lot of money do
the exact opposite of everything people
love that I mean it is probably the most
direct route yeah to the type of
economic success I think a lot of right
the why not
yeah but I think if you want to have
people if you want to have a community I
knew better than money I know when I'm
asked if the only thing I say to people
all the time about the only thing I've
said at the end of a something I've
written is this thing has happened to me
that it didn't need to be written I mean
that's what journals are for and I get
in trouble when I say that but I'm I
stand by it there is a difference
between writing in my journal and
writing for sense-making in place making
and argumentation and I think one of the
first steps we can learn is the
difference that's what I think a
community should teach you that's what
being in a community of people are
supposed to teach you that that is
fascinating and it is a journal entry
and now let's talk about what that would
look like as a short story of essay or a
novel right it's about learning genre I
think
we don't tend to be very good at this as
academics but I think it is learning and
respecting genre so one of the ways that
I try to keep a check on myself is to
read the genre that I'm writing in but
outside of my subject area expertise so
for example in writing thick I don't
think there's much in it that could
qualify as a camera essay but I read
tons of humorist
because I think they do a wonderful job
with the form of the essay and I wanted
to be able to focus on that rather than
one the content so I read a lot of that
and so I know I've done it if I can see
the form I can see the structure and
what I've written and if at the end of
it it's about something other than me
but then but really honestly at the end
you can't ever be the ultimate check on
that that's where the community of
people come from you have to show it to
other people and that's a relationship
by the way I have a black woman editor
tell people all the time I probably be
publishing a thing if I didn't have a
black woman editing me because the
amount of trust it takes to have
somebody work through some of your most
complicated thinking and emotional
processes and to trust them when they
say it's there or it's not there is a
relationship it is not something you can
just mail off to it was something on the
web on a website I'm sorry I think that
is wonderful for maybe structure or copy
editing but the actual what an editor
actually does for you is a creative
marriage and relationship in its best
sense I think and that is what that
person I think is there to help you do
to know at the end whether you've hit
that mark or not and I think a lot of
writers I mean and of course that's also
one of the hardest things for us to get
right an editor who's invested in you in
that way and then you're working that
way who'll come to know how you think
well enough to help you think better and
to write better and that's tough but at
the end of day I don't know that you're
the only person who can determine that I
think other people have to help you
figure it out one of the greatest
compliments to me is when someone reads
me and they say I thought I knew
everything about that yeah I thought I
knew how you make toast and you just
change the entire toast making process
for me
that's what I want to do and that
cinnamon is a game-changer right I'll
tell you what he was doing it you all
know about cinnamon like I want to mess
that whole thing up yep you know I
recently edited an anthology called not
that bad and I received about 330
submissions and of those 300 or so the
submissions were testimony we're just
people telling me about the worst
experience of their lives and the number
one question I get from young writers is
I have a story that deserves to be told
and that's all they say like and they
really think that they've said something
when they say this and they have but
everyone's story deserves to be told so
why yours just because you went through
it it's not enough and so that's the
rubric that I'm using like you have to
offer more than just testimony it cannot
be a recitation of what you've been
through you have to contextualize it you
have to place it in a broader cultural
discourse and if you're not doing that
if you're not approaching it with what
some of the things we are talking about
earlier like nuance and complexity and
dimensionality then no yeah your story
deserves to be told but I don't want to
hear it it comes back to the stat the
scabbing question - I would think is a
very different helps a lot it does
that's why I think again I talk about
cases working some other who are able to
have that level of complexity and their
writing even though they're still in the
middle of it is a level of artistry that
quite frankly I think you know very few
people achieve with a piece of work most
of us I suspect need to have some
distance to do it well and I think
saying you'd hit it earlier to Roxanne's
point about dimensionality and quite
enemy wants all of that takes humility
yeah absolutely
Viola Davis she gave an interview that I
got was it was subtle it was quick I
think it was a million times but I got
was incredibly bold because there is
such a huge risk for actors to talk
about past work right and and she always
talks about like even as lauded as she
is like it's still just so precarious
because she is a darker skinned black
woman
you know over the age of 40 and you know
someone asked her about regrets Wow
you know like you Hollywood you're never
supposed to have any regrets every movie
you've done supposed to be the best
movie and she said the help and I think
one other film which I was like well I'd
never thought I thought we were gonna
have to wait like 50 years before Viola
Davis would talk about how she felt
about playing a maid in the help like
wow you know and she said I learned that
it's one thing to make the movie it's
another thing to then have to go out
there and promote it I was like wow I
mean you have Viola Davis
I just think one of our master artists
right like truly she is in our tour of
performance she can embody any character
you put in front of her I absolutely
believe that but she was like that's not
the question
the question is you know two years after
all of that when you moved on to other
projects I've done that and now it's you
know promo time and junkets indebted how
are you going to feel when you have to
sit you know again and again and I sit
and like doing a morning show I sit
across from these people and they're
like okay I'm on my way to the next show
just came from you know when you're
gonna have to do this again and again
and the podcast interviews and the
written interviews and all the panel's
how are you going to feel talking about
this piece it is one thing to write it
is again very different to be out there
and to really advocate for it and and
the reason I think that hits so hard for
writers is that I believe if you are a
good writer or a reader and I believe
you all are you're here you care we care
deeply and and we can't turn it off and
so I do really feel that when we're in
those situations and I think we've been
in the maybe in different ways you know
where you're like whoa you know I didn't
realize what I was getting myself into
it hits really hard and so I think about
her a lot for that reason so are we
ready to open up to the audience
yeah y'all still out there I think we
have a couple of people with microphones
what if you can wave them around and if
you have a question wave your hand
around and then the microphone people
will find you yes and if you're in the
balcony just stand up and we'll hear you
it's a church I didn't God is watching
you sort of stretch tentatively which
could just be Emily we got a couple over
here
oh no I kind of like it when people are
like stretching and taking their time
because that's how you know they're
actually thinking about a question you
know
we can hear you we can say it out you
can repeat it back yeah
I'm not resilient I don't recover
quickly I need years yes Ari so the
question was about indigenous people
using the terms resilient and strong and
does Torres think that those questions
are useful or are they terms that keep
indigenous people in the past I think
you know I think majority white culture
would love us to be resilient and
empower and reconstitute ourselves in an
assimilated world and but I'm angry and
hurt you know and I think I've seen the
DNA artist named Janelle Cronin she will
she made little stickers that had a blue
blue rose and it wrote mozillian and for
her that meant everything it was a
symbol of her being on a continuum that
could not be erased but for me I am NOT
resilient and I don't want to be a meme
I don't I don't want to I see it in
means it's like a woman with braids
wrapped in a blanket she's resilient and
I'm just the opposite like messy and
like crying and drinking diet coke like
you know I'm just not that yeah a symbol
oh yeah
thank you I love that question and that
answer twisting because I think it
happens in all of our cultures it's like
a rough idea I mean if you're bold and
resilient was strong black women yeah we
don't need no man excellent you like
that might be true yeah but the MENA
fication of everybody's culture
and we excellent but like you know as
audre Lorde's I mean I think that's what
I'll do is pushing back everything she
says if you're silent they'll kill you
surely you enjoyed it
right resilience means you deserve
everything we inflicted upon you you can
never ask properly right because you can
never name what's been done to you if
you're resilient so yeah it's a
wonderful tool for colonialism yeah
they're a bunch of hands being raised in
the back why don't you stand if you have
a question so that they can actually see
you take on your legs there you go
thank you guys bro hi yeah he's mine I
got there you go can you hear me yeah
yeah hi I'm very curious after all this
talk about watching people eat
themselves I want to know why I
personally think that people would want
to see how they see themselves I know
the dimensions just the just the economy
of this tourism and being able to walk
away unscathed but why else do you think
people would be attracted to seeing
other people hurt oh that's the question
why would people want to be attracted to
watching people hurt when we talk about
this tourism but it's escapism that
people do into other people's
experiences do I did I have your
question right
oh and that we talked a bit about the
economics of it but why I think it's the
same reason people like to ride roller
coasters and I say that a little
judgment cuz I don't like to ride roller
coasters it's like you want to feel like
you're falling off a building but you
don't want to have to hit the ground
that's your brain splattered everywhere
you know I mean like trauma like I don't
say this word in a positive way but it
is thrilling in the sense of like a
thriller right like you
you there's no adrenaline rush like
having a gun 2 centimeters from your
head and a crazy person on the other end
of it I promise you that I mean you will
never feel anything like that in your
life and if you don't have to actually
feel the certainty of death I could see
how that could be a little bit fun yeah
having all your hormones spiked at one
time but you can't really get one
without the other unless you have a very
capable writer who has gone through it
who can simulate the experience for you
that you can then have in the safety and
comfort of your own home when it starts
to get a little too much you can just
close your book and have a cup of tea I
mean I think you know we like to do
these thrilling experiences but you
don't want to have the actual cost
that's associated with it yeah it's a
basic arousal response people want
awareness because they want to
congratulate themselves for the
awareness of something but like I think
that's part of it too
yeah there's a perience I mean there's a
reason why Criminal Minds has been on
for what 15 seasons Law & Order SVU has
been on for 19 there's something
voyeuristic and watching the suffering
of others without having to actually
experience that suffering yourself and
it's human nature and I don't think it's
a good part of human nature but we have
to acknowledge it nonetheless yeah I I
feel I feel terrible for people who feel
this way and I pity them too because I I
think so many people are dead inside
they may even say it but I don't think
they were perhaps fully aware and I'm
saying this is someone who felt this way
at one point in my life to aren't fully
aware of how true that is and they are
looking for ways to feel again and and I
think it is it is true in terms of the
content the entertainment the art they
are drawn to it probably manifests
frankly in all kinds of ways but when
you see the way people were
- like you know I think reporting about
Amy clover char is really interesting to
see how people like not everyone but
right many people are like oh well tuck
bosses and you're like wait a minute
wait a minute what's going on are Kelly
Michael Jetson you see we see constantly
how well people have rationalized you
know their own trauma and and what
happens and so yeah I think one of the
manifestations of that that deadness
that many people enact frankly just to
get from one day to the next in America
right is that when there's an
opportunity to try on someone else's
skin suit you feel something there is an
arousal there is a sexiness there is a I
feel something if not just for a moment
because it wow I mean this is horrible
and I think intellectually people
understand that no one wants to be the
victim a law-and-order but we keep
watching
I don't think those who handheld
microphones are work maybe we could turn
the volume play with that this is
another piece of the cannibalizing that
if you forget rotten you were saying if
someone has to feel scathed by reading
it that if the the meat of the story is
all coming out of the author that's
that's where we get what you're
describing right whereas if some of it
is coming from the reader you get out of
your cannibalism oh did that buy us
enough time do we have a mic good so we
try just shouting your term forward
white people have been shouting in
chapels for so long
[Laughter]
good welcome
yes my dears again that means you're in
the right place
thank you for that and for the ride I
belong here either so it's all good
welcome we see I know you have a
question here in the front row you sure
sure
[Music]
they always catch the play yeah they
will catch the bad guy that's a great
question so how much do it thank you
yeah how much does Shane play into the
work huge and so much so much III I
think for all of us right but certainly
if you're right enough sexing and the
body I shame I went through college and
and and only you know maybe six years
out of college - did I realize that I
was actually chronically depressed as a
college student like actually textbook
and I was hiding it in textbook ways by
being a successful student right and it
was all shame it was all shame about sex
it was it was it was the shame that I
think in particular is posed on queer
people where the the big lie of shame
and America about queerness is that
coming out is actually the great work
and it is not the great work is is that
to come out in America as a queer person
means that you publicly every time you
come out over and over and over again
every day and day and day you are
recognizing that you have a different
relationship to sex and desire then than
most people and America shames us you
know and and so yeah it exhausted me and
so to go back to actually your very
first question that the time travel that
is for me when can I find Syed Jones in
the time line at those different seminal
moments where shame seeped into my body
because that's what it does it seeps
into our bodies like a poison and it
stays with us for so long and it's so
difficult to undo and I think you know
for queer people and just obviously for
men like what is toxic masculinity if
you flip the coin its shame that's what
it is and it's so in
credibly dangerous obviously so in some
ways I feel like that's my project
you know that's my my life's project is
is to to to flip the coin um and to look
at shame because it's just terrifying
the process of sharing has actually been
really helpful and erasing some of that
you know I think like I think shame a
lot of the feeling of shame is just
feeling like you're complicit and what
happened to you or you're alone in what
happened to you and no one else feels
like this you're the only one and having
written about some of these experiences
you know like with being turned away by
doctors I mean I felt like I wasn't a
good patient you know I wasn't loud
enough and then hearing other people say
oh no that's not just you that happened
to me ii was really validating and
similarly you know i written i made a
comic about my experience of getting
like held hostage at gunpoint for a
while by this crazy lunatic and i didn't
write about it for a really long time
because i i didn't really remember it I
had this weird thing happening in my
memory where I knew that it had happened
and I felt traumatized but I didn't have
like a real it's difficult to explain
it's like there's something in there but
it's chaos you know I couldn't remember
well a lot about it
a significant portion of it and it felt
like to say that would be to say well
then I didn't really experience trauma
you know can you even have trauma
without a conscious memory of something
that happened and then it's in writing
yeah right big answer is yes yes in
writing the comic about I did a lot of
research in memory and trauma and the
way that that interacts and it it healed
me you know like being able to write
that and say like yeah I my trauma is
legitimate even if my memory is altered
you know that that was really healing
for me yeah I also just would say I
would also it doesn't get it gets
it gets better enact me Oh fighting back
on shame um it doesn't necessarily get
easier at least from me I don't maybe
you feel differently but it is like from
sentence to sentence you know and then
again and I can say this like I
literally started writing about what
happened as soon as it I didn't go to
therapy I didn't talk to family I didn't
get support i sat down and started
writing because that was the only thing
that made me feel powerful even having
that sense of authority you know I was
stunned by the persistence of doubt and
shame and the way they kind of tag-team
one another to keep you second guessing
yourself every step of the way and so I
would also say you know we've taught a
lot I think a lot about emerging writers
but I don't know if any point in our
careers or our lives combating the way
our brains engage with shame and and and
self-doubt is any less challenging like
it's always going to be like Serena
Williams on the other side of the net
responsibility to a community of people
made the shame I mean I think there's
book there was both the shame of my
experiences and then the shame of
telling them when I know that I can't I
was not going to be able to control how
the the gaze that saw it right so the
thing is when you're writing as a black
woman you're always representing a group
of people whether you choose to or not
and more importantly whether they choose
you to or not and I'm and I'm acutely
aware of that fact right it's why works
so hard to locate my position and things
and why I push back against being a
singular voice on anything and why I
want to talk to the universal black
woman's experience without talking about
it being universal right and why I try
so hard to do all of that because I
don't want my shame to be anyone else's
and at the same time there is a
inherited legacy mostly from being
marginalized and oppressed and demonized
the majority white culture of black
women not being allowed to share the
kind of vulnerability one needs to have
to do the kind of writing that is
related to writing about trauma we're
not supposed to have your black women
are supposed to be able to have Tron
we aren't even supposed to have to be
able to have that kind of vulnerability
and we may not be ready to show the
underbelly when I'm ready to write about
it and so I felt a particular type of
responsibility to knowing that that gaze
would be there and whether or not I was
sharing my shame or anyone elses shame
and and I think I'd be writing again the
specificity helped a great deal and in
many ways though the shame was how I
knew where I needed to write perversely
right you almost kind of have to start
there and work it and write your way out
of it and write your way through it but
yeah I thought about it a lot both my
chain and other people's and how that
shame might be interpreted by others
yeah I'm telling it I was about to say
it's not a speak loud and alright thank
you it's not us thank you
yeah you know so the question whatever
the question was about sort of reading
something very very graphic and feeling
moved by that and connecting to one's
own experience and where the boundaries
around how where that is perience where
that's moving moving us individually
yeah for me it's just how do you are the
details and service of something more
than just being Korean just being
gratuitous and I believe in explicitness
when writing about violates and I'm very
explicit and pretty much all of my work
when I do try to choose to write about
violence because I think people need to
know the reason we still have people who
say oh I didn't know it was that bad I
didn't know that this many women deal
with sexual harassment for example which
we've seen a lot of people say since the
rise of me too is because we're not
specific enough often enough and I think
that there's a lot of value in reading
specificity and explicitness in the in
the experiences of others when as for
you and mirror is something that you've
been through there's I find that to be
very healing to know oh my god I'm not
alone I am not the only one who knows
how terrible this specific thing is and
so as long as it's in service of that I
think it's not at all gratuitous you
know when it's wrong you really do in
these over lists eyelas things them
there's a movie and I can't remember the
name but there are two versions of the
movie and it's about a woman who's
assaulted by her ex-boyfriend when she
and her husband are visiting their her
country home somewhere and I can't
remember the name of the movie but in it
they make the rape scene seem sensual
and quite lovely and it's rape it's not
supposed to be sensual or lovely and
she's clearly traumatized by it and
that's when you know okay that's wrong
that's not a good idea because they
truly make it seem like this really
romantic thing and it's not so you just
have to use common sense
but I go to explicitness is not
necessarily a bad thing
and I'm all for it quite obviously
okay so we've got a sort of
double-barreled question one about
asking each of you about how you're
writing about and thinking about trauma
and memory and a sort of specific
question for me and my other role about
whether or not the people who sit on our
disciplinary board learn about trauma
and memory yes they do I do that and
others do as well there's a lot of
training but for you when you're writing
I mean you started us down the path but
yeah yeah I mean I I have written
especially in that one comic just really
explicitly about it like breaking down
the science of like here's what happens
when your adrenaline Rises and here's
what you know cortisol does and I don't
know if this is too much information for
that question but like as a very quick
primer basically when you're
experiencing trauma it aids your body
your brain in storage of memory like it
makes those memories really really
sticky and really vivid but it makes it
very difficult to retrieve them so if
you don't do it right away and you don't
do it often and you don't beat yourself
a clear path to accessing those memories
you lose them access to them but they're
there you just can't get them and when
you're thinking about your trauma the
visual side of your brain is going crazy
like it really lights up the sensory
side but the verbal side shuts down so
it's very chaotic it's challenging to
make a narrative like if you try to like
relive the experience the same you would
way you would relive like your morning
routine like okay I got up and brush my
teeth it's kind of see it like a movie
in your head it makes a lot of sense
trauma how it gets encoded in memory
it's chaos your brain doesn't you know
cross the midline it's not weaving
together the sensory stuff with the
narrative stuff and it's it can be a
mess so if you don't talk about what
happened to you immediately and you try
not to think about it which is what I
did I said well I'm not going to think
about that that way I don't have to
think about it which is awful
then you don't your brain doesn't learn
to make that connection early enough and
it can make it more difficult to kind of
heal from it later you just explained
everything I've ever my immediate
reaction was to go to my dorm and start
writing down what happened it also
explains I would say and I I tried to
explain this to people before with my
poetry collection prelude to Bruges
which is about a character named boy who
was black and gay and in America and
experiences violence and peril but is
not me part of it is you know America's
relationship to poetry in the eye you
all know we're yellow you get it but but
what I when I try to explain people was
that before I got to the point of
maturity therapy support that I could
coherent leave begin to make sense of
not just what happened to me in these
traumatic experiences but connecting the
dots to all of the different memories
I'm looking at Roxanne because she's
read the book she's ready I'm talking
about the memories that you know are so
significant before I could do that
poetry which was struggling so prelude
to Bruges is really the kaleidoscope you
know version of what happened to me boys
story is not my story but if but when I
look at it I see like oh like this is
like what I was these poems are like
what I was dreaming about as I was
trying to find my way back to that room
in my brain you know I'll send you a
link sighs thanks girls I guess I had
very few memories of I really didn't
want to remember and I was okay with
that but when I wanted to cultivate a
work explaining certain things I didn't
I didn't know how to put things in scene
because I only remembered a few lines of
dialogue so what i did was i centered
those in the nair
like my mother when I am a teenager and
I ask her did my father hurt me I
remember distinctly she said I put you
in double diapers there's no way he hurt
you did he hurt you and then nothing
else I remembered nothing else but that
was enough for the reader to understand
and and then I contextualize that
narrative Lee for them to understand
that the trajectory of my life led up to
its in the same essay where I just give
a list all the horrible men I dated and
I just say one I punctured with a fork I
he heard me when I said no you know one
I you know and I just list it because
that's all they need they don't need
names
they don't need characterization they
don't need dynamism so I'm like you see
the perspective the narrative fits even
though it's fragmented you know that's
really important craft wines yeah for me
I focus a lot in terms of the
psychological aspects I'm PTSD and the
lingering of trauma and how that shapes
memory because for me what it has meant
is I can be having a normal day and then
I'll smell beer on someone's breath and
all of a sudden I have all of the
memories and it just appears and I try
to find ways of communicating that in
both my fiction and nonfiction that
memory is not just this visual
recitation of something that you've been
through but that sometimes you have
these flashes when you least expect them
and how do you deal with them when
you're just going about your business
having a day and then your life intrudes
and I'm very interested in that because
we don't talk a lot about PTSD in these
specific ways we talk about it as this
container for the aftermath and it's not
really well understood and I try to
address that as best I can
I had a lot of memories
in my in my mind I you know the joke I
my friends or family is you know there's
there's the before trustee in the after
trustee and actually my memory it could
what you know trauma changes you
fundamentally alters things in you I'm
like sigh you get explained there's so
much in my life and truly yeah because
they you know it is that my memories are
they feel quite different before the
trauma than the ones after the trauma
and then the memories of the trauma it
feels different even from those other
two and so one of the things I had to
grapple with was how much was I gonna
trust myself right and so you know I
went through this manic phase of trying
to go through every diary I had and I
have written most of my life so you know
I had these scraps of parts of my what I
knew at different moments in time and
they were helpful in priming just to
remind me of how it felt to be me at a
point in time which helped me understand
why a memory was fuzzy if that makes
sense so it helped me with the with the
tempo of time you know the timeline and
then I had you know and then there was
just a decision I had to make that I had
to trust my body's memories as much as I
did my you know what we think of really
as memory our cognitive memory I did
trust my emotions I trust what I felt
and I had to give that some you know
equal weight and my narrative and
understanding and trusting myself to
write it and then I had to be honest
about the parts I you know I used
details and metaphor a lot for that
reason from me the way shouldn't poetry
was the structure of fractured memory
for you and I think the way you situate
what you can remember and say no this
will serve and nothing the narrative and
centering and the narrative for me it
was about I will Brown mine in the
details that I do know and I actually
get readers have told me a lot you know
like I just just tell me the one people
respond you know tell me about the essay
you know that essay about the ribs
they'll say you know I'm Leslie it's not
about ribs at all it's just that I
remember the ribs that were sitting on
the table when we had the conversation
where my family looked at me and told me
who was allowed to be raped
wasn't right who was good and who wasn't
and where I was supposed to fall on that
line I have remembered the ribs and so
for me I Center the most concrete of
those memories and then very similarly
structured the rest of the narrative as
they around it
similarly for me being in the hospital
and about to give birth and I've been in
labor for like five days and you know
it's there at the end and realized we
can't hold it off and they haven't shown
up yet with the epidural and it's all
very horrible and all I can remember is
when the anesthesiologist finally showed
up what the needle felt like piercing my
spine so that for me is where this
narrative started it was the most
concrete of the details that I had and I
start and go there but it was also just
trusting that yeah that life is not you
know a series of empirical facts and
data that operated in this way and
leaning into it rather than saying I
think some writers are more inclined to
believe this by the way than others just
culturally who we say will we will
distrust right so we start to doubt
ourselves and it was just me saying I
wouldn't doubt myself about it also I
want to say too because it's something
it's just in this conversation it's very
apparent and and what I've read if
you're working out I'm like I can't wait
to go back and read so much more of
everyone's work here it's that you're
very candid about what you know what
you're trying to know what you remember
what you know like it that is and I feel
that way am i writing to like it's part
of the project like I'm not I'm not a
reliable narrator I don't think any of
us are and I just admire and at least
myself gravitate towards writers who do
that because I just I feel that is true
and once you embrace like listen I'm an
unreliable narrator but I believe in the
mission of what I'm trying to do let's
go you know I think that's a powerful
relationship for writer leader and it
opens up so much more space for we were
talking earlier about the need to be
able to tell a trauma story that has a
whole person in it and not just one
slice of an innocent victim in the midst
of it even though that is one
the slices that unreliable narrator is
precisely not the person who walks
through step by step you know one or two
more questions some of those people in
the back we see we see all of your hands
we'll try you ain't giving up my
question to someone in the back huh
right there yep yes sister right there
yes hello
so uh full disclosure I'm a psychiatrist
I said my question was grounded in that
but also a question about writing about
drama as a person a lot of those
supports that you've talked about sound
informal and I wonder what formal
supports in deciding what to talk about
what is your narrative what do you
recollect what are the ramifications of
telling your stories what formal
supports have you accessed in that
journey and have they been helpful or
counterproductive so for me as someone
who's grounded in the dsm-5 talking
about PTSD with my patients that's one
way of intellectualizing trauma or
traumatic experiences but if I were
reflecting on my own that's more of a
visceral personal process and I'm just
thinking through what it means to
reconcile those two things so that's me
as a professional but I wonder and you
all accessing possibly formal supports
how do you fit that all in into your
process I don't draw a lot on formal
supports because I don't have
because when I was assaulted I was 12
years old and I didn't tell anyone I did
go to therapy but I would that was I was
that was at Exeter in 1988 and so that
therapist I don't even remember their
name honestly so I don't have any sort
of formal structural resources upon
which I can draw from I'm drawing
entirely from informal structures
including memory and little things I
would write over the years I wouldn't
call it a diary but like a blog this
thing that used to exist called live
journal and so I I think that's one of
the hallmarks of a lot of the kinds of
trauma especially the trauma everyone up
here has experienced is that because I
don't think any of us really trusted the
justice system in any way or knew that
we could we don't have any sort of
formal codification and in some ways
that's a blessing but in many ways
that's a curse when I was I just like
the way memories surface when I was
selling the proposal for this book I was
fortunate enough that several publishers
eight publishers ended up bidding on it
which again like I was saying like the
only good scenario was and I will never
forget sitting in the office of an
editor in New York who identified as a
queer woman and and being so excited to
sit across from this person and she the
first thing she said was you know we're
gonna have to we have to talk with
lawyers with this I had to look over it
she has to meet me by the way and she's
like why didn't you report it that was
the first thing she said why didn't you
report it how and she was because at the
time the essay the book actually opened
in Phoenix Arizona with with this this
incident with this guy and I just
remember she's talking and I was looking
at my back
and I was like site you need to make eye
contact with this woman you know and I
realized because I was really like part
of my brain was like you need to get up
and leave so to say like the
relationship of distrust to formal
structures it's there and it's real I
will say I'm fortunate that I have
health insurance that has allowed me to
be in therapy for the last few years in
part because I work in news in America I
need all the help I can get you know it
is unexpectedly you know and working on
the book it has been such a grace
actually that when something comes up
even the good news I got some good news
last week that I was sharing with
Roxanne and I was so happy during the
day and by the time I got to my hotel
room that night I was just a wreck and
to be able to have a conversation about
like grief is back you know wow you know
even good news can you know in its way
trigger unexpected you know violent
reactions and sad reactions it was
therapy being able to do that but yeah
absolutely I didn't trust nobody are you
kidding me and it's to the point about
institutional support so when I was
robbed at gunpoint
we were the perfect victims it was like
me my baby sister my boyfriend we were
in her house and it was the middle of
the night just a crazy lunatic just
busted in the house in the middle of the
night and like lined us all up on the
floor and it was the whole thing and we
you know we like we felt great about our
victimhood status you know and we called
the police immediately and said there's
a man with a gun in our house you know
I'm like hung up we couldn't even like
make sentences and then when the police
got there they first accused us of
inventing the entire story and when we
said like where's all our stuff stuff
you know where's my sister's car then
they switch their tactic to saying why
would you give him your wallets why
would you give him your car you just
helped him attack the next people and it
was like extremely rich hama tithing
like you just want the police to come
and like make you feel safe and you want
someone especially like when you're
still in the very tender aftermath to
say like oh my god like poor baby come
here are you okay and it was the
opposite of that it was like blaming us
and we were all crying we just wanted
them to leave and then you know they
were there for like four more hours
fingerprinting everything and
interviewing us over and over again
about things we couldn't remember you
know it was like a whole thing so it's I
mean I don't know like can we ever rely
on our institutions totally I don't know
I want us to be able to but what I'm
writing is about exactly that though
that how the institutions not only do
not help but in many ways either
facilitate the trauma you know are
responsible for the trauma or reach
remote eyes and so I'm generally talking
about that every day lived experience of
again bureaucratic institutional
traumatic trauma enacted upon people and
so no I very rarely I mean I you know I
also had interactions listen there was a
a man sitting outside my house once he
had done the the taxi scam you know
where he claimed he couldn't take a
credit card once he dropped you off and
you know he had to have cash and so he
wanted to force me to go to the ATM and
I wouldn't go and so he blocked me in at
my house and standing outside ranting
raving it's 2:00 a.m. in the morning I
live alone and in that moment I thought
I wish I had somebody to call it
literally never occurred to me to call
literally never that is a trauma I would
who was thinking about how was I going
to deal with the crazy man who was
trying to kick in my door and it never
called occurred to me to call the police
because you don't fix trauma with trauma
and you don't fix where I come from you
know I'm just as vulnerable in one
situation as I am in another and in many
ways that's exactly what I'm writing
about even in trying to someone at one
of the places where I have found for
example in talking about and writing
about my expand
maternal health care in this country as
a black woman
one of the more hopeful spots for me
have been the sort of community-based
institutional correctives which is you
know doula communities and community
health partners and etc we try to
respond to those systemic failures and
I've found that to be helpful in the
sense that it does remind me that what
has happened to me one doesn't have to
have to happen to other people but that
it has happened enough that people have
figured out how to do something about it
somehow gives me some strange sort of
comfort and so I very rarely appeal to
formal institutions find some comfort
and community based institutions and in
the same way just think I mean it just
doesn't it wouldn't even occur to me to
do otherwise what's that sorry I don't
know why I laugh I mean I go host that's
so horrible that all I can do is laugh
and we have to I mean I I will be
thinking about this sentence for the
rest of my life but indelible in the
hippocampus is the laughter when dr.
Christine Blasi Ford said it was like a
lightning bolt like felt you know it's
just my god and so we have images it's
hard to even talk about right to have
seen so viscerally that play out on the
national stage and the stakes being what
they are for a Supreme Court justice
confirmation what could be more
traumatize that that is that is me that
is the epitome of power structures and
so what could be more traumatic than all
of us being wherever we were reading and
watching and listening to see how that
plays out and to see what a woman who's
talking about something that happened to
her when she was a teenager to see how
its adjudicated not just like in
American culture but literally in the
American power structure it just it to
me to go well okay
it's what is more what is more
destabilizing for our faith in these
power structures than to actually need
them in a moment of personal crisis all
right we have time for one last question
that's right oh right right
I'd like do it all up there we go
great question
you want to start yeah I had a question
back so at what point did we feel ready
to write our stories and at what point
did we feel ready and secure enough to
share those stories I for my MSA I had a
thesis that was fiction and it was with
a native woman protagonist who had a lot
of bravado and there was always a murky
dark ending and every story and then I
knew is me you know and it's not murky I
was hurt and I know exactly how and each
time and like I reported one rape
against me at the detective never called
me back you know my father went to jail
for abducting a kid he knows like I
don't care about the system system
doesn't care about me I know it could
take away my kids that's what I know
about a system so like for me writing I
knew I'd be only accountable to my
family you know to my brothers whose
story was very close to mine we were all
abused so I had to get his go-ahead and
once I started talking he helped me fill
in the gaps on how my dad really left
and things like that
so it took like eight years eight years
of just knowing like trying to figure
out what happened in the view of
everybody else and who I was going to be
accountable to not my ex-husband not his
family to my brother's to Native women
you know and that was pretty much it to
my mother you know and then I was ready
to be public about that and it's just
the way everybody's talked about is and
only for it you only have two further
you you have to keep excavating things
they keep asking for more and I think
you have to be really good at saying no
and I think once you have those things
you're ready yeah it took me 22 years to
get to a place where I could publicly
publish something
about what I had been through and I
wasn't ready I truly wasn't and I'm
never ready when I published something
terrifying but I do it anyway so I'm in
a place where I know I can handle doing
it anyway
but 22 years and therapy for pretty much
all of those 22 years and some
medication as well which goes a long way
better living through chemistry so
strange for me and then I think so far
what I'm hearing is I think you'll know
when you are enough of the person you're
supposed to be if that makes sense
right each of us maybe needed something
a little different to be that but my
experience of watching other people and
asking actually a very similar question
to many people when I was trying to
determine whether or not I was ready was
I don't know at some point you are
yourself I think that is whether that's
professional success you are at a point
in your life you have been through
therapy I don't know whatever that thing
is that you needed to feel yourself and
when that happens for me anyway what
happened was I don't know I couldn't not
write it it was the thing when I started
saying what can I uniquely say what can
I write that no one else can write that
might matter right and that I can do
better than anyone else could have done
it and what did I ever want to give up
to anyone else I don't want to see this
story to anyone else to tell it for me
when I was confident about who I wasn't
for me that was about I'll be honest
about a certain amount of professional
comfort because if I wasn't want to take
the risk of telling my story I knew I
was risking it not only for myself but
for people I cared about I needed to be
able to protect them right and so some
of being your my professional statues
that I couldn't do that I could say no I
could say no sometimes we can't say no
and that's just the reality right that's
not about like the spiritual woo-hoo-hoo
no that's about I don't know can you say
no and still eat next we like those are
sometimes the practical considerations
it was about finally being a person who
could who knew how who could articulate
it because when you can say no you've
learned to value yourself in a
particular kind of way
and you know yourself in a particular
kind of way and I do think you have to
have that grounding before you do it and
then because I don't know what's out
ready to share it again
somewhere along that along the pathway
there I'd made relationships with people
that I was willing to share it with
right and once it becomes circulated in
your small community I think that you
start to acclimate yourself to the idea
that this will have a public right and
then I do think that you're ready the
like the system and stuff like that I
knew if I had written about drinking or
anything like that it might be unlikely
they might call CPS on me to do an
investigation again cuz I had that when
I was a welfare mom you know so have
money to litigate if somebody is good
for ya I think that's really important
too to have the cushion of like I'm can
defend myself
absolutely I had my PhD or I was just
about I was actually in grad short
school getting my PhD but I knew in my
soul I was gonna get a tenure track job
I don't know how but I was right and so
knowing that I could write whatever I
wanted to write without losing my job
and my means of supporting myself I made
it a lot easier to be able to tell my
story
yeah for me I'm ready to put it out you
know and write it when I can do two
things one is to find the what is this
something else so that it's not just the
traumas ooh and then the other thing is
how can I put form to the chaos because
for me if it's trauma then it is chaos
in my head it's not in the untidy
narrative and coming into comics which I
just started like about two and a half
years ago has really opened a lot of
doors for me in that I don't think I
could have written about the robbery in
words because it was you know like I
said it's not in my brain that way it's
in my brain in images so that was really
important also I have roxanne mentioned
the anthology not that bad earlier
and I have an essay in that book which
is very structurally bonkers you know
it's got like sections that are math
problems it's all over the place because
that's the only way I could put form to
that particular chaos so once I can
figure out how to lasso that chaos into
something that I can show to somebody
else and it will make sense and then
once I understand what it even is I'm
trying to tell them then that's when I'm
ready everything that has been said
absolutely the support the the cultural
capital financial capital finding your
people time just be reading more
becoming a better writer all of those
things contribute you just know it you
only you can know and even then you
don't really but you know you develop
that intuition and you have to trust it
I guess two things I mean you know one
it was about ten years you know again I
was always writing it I was felt safe
and workshops and everything that was
always fine very head down I'll write
whatever but publishing took about ten
years I met a man named Isaac Fitzgerald
who was a wonderful editor and became my
best friend and he made me feel very
safe and he introduced me to a woman
named Roxane gay and she was a wonderful
editor and writer and she made me a very
sane and that's how I published the
essay but the other thing too was that I
was just so I was moving toward at this
point like this is like 2012 I was
moving toward a job that eventually
became the job at BuzzFeed and becoming
an LGBT editor building the vertical
there I was just so aware of the peril
like I mean we're still like toxic
masculinity all of these things it's
like kind of a day one conversation but
in 2012 I was like my god like the
pervasiveness of hate crimes and the
pervasiveness of what I think of is I
don't know like ghosts crimes which are
like the unreported violence against
queer people that's involved with
relationships and it's just like even
messier than you were walking down the
street and someone accosted you was just
so clear to me
and people were being gunned down just
it seemed like left and
and and you know transform it was just
everywhere and I was so I just felt so
aware of the dearth of good
we're really any writing about
internalized homophobia and internalized
sexism and gay men I just I could not
find enough books or essays about the
way gay men and take all everything
we've said tonight in and in that
machismo
to our detriment our obsession with
straight white men and and and violent
and what that does to us I just wasn't
seeing it and my people were dying and
so I just felt like or we got we got to
put something out there you know and I
don't know if I'm the best person but
I'm gonna do my best and and I think for
all of us you just the pain eventually
frankly of withholding it becomes too
much you know and you do your best so I
am sure everybody else have many more
questions but I'm looking at the time I
am so grateful to be part of the
public's that you're talking to that
that each of you have found your way
through the time through the support
through the great editors to wanting to
put these things out here thank you for
enacting this community for us tonight
on stage thank you thank you thank you
we are going to have a five minute
reorganisation break and then our
panelists are very generously going to
stay and sign books for a little bit so
thank you all for having been a
wonderful audience
[Music]